las autoridades georgianas trasladaron
al ex presidente mikhaíl saakashvili a
un hospital militar luego de que un
panel médico asegurara que sufre de
problemas renales y neurológicos el
opositor pasó 50 días en una huelga de
hambre bajo custodia saakashvili dejó de
alimentarse desde el primero de octubre
cuando fue detenido tras su regreso a
georgia después de varios años en el
exilio desde temprano miles de
simpatizantes del exmandatario
manifestaron en las calles de la capital
pidiendo su liberación
lamentablemente georgia está bajo
régimen me refiero a la oligarquía a la
cleptocracia
desafortunadamente aquí no hay
democracia por eso el gobierno actuó de
manera tan irresponsable con respecto a
su vida
somos firmes a nuestro anuncio de que no
vamos a tener mítines cerca del hospital
donde se entregara sakashvili
pero lucharemos por su libertad y
lucharemos por unas elecciones
parlamentarias justas y proporcionales
en un comunicado el ex mandatario dijo
que volvería a comer después del
traslado al hospital pero que nunca
aceptaría su detención ilegal mikhaíl
saakashvili de 53 años fue presidente de
la ex república soviética de 2004 a 2013
en 2013 ese exilio en ucrania y luego
fue declarado culpable por abuso de
poder y condenado a 6 años de prisión
pero el opositor rechaza los cargos por
motivos políticos el encarcelamiento del
reformista pre occidental ha agravado
aún más la crisis política en el país
que comenzó con las elecciones
legislativas de 2020 cuando triunfo del
partido oficialista sin embargo el
resultado fue considerado como
fraudulento por la oposición